hi there it's kevin van or standing in
for reviewer Lafe johnson to tell you
about the open beta for hearthstone
hearthstone is the kind of game that
leaves you eager for another round this
is Magic the Gathering stripped of all
its clutter and it thrives on one on one
15-minute card battles that will likely
occupy scores of lunch breaks for years
to come hearthstone step isn't
immediately apparent in the compact 30
card deck but then few developers are so
adept at stripping complex concepts down
to their essentials as blizzard and in a
characteristic Blizzard touch not all
the fun comes from the play the most
powerful cards thump bond the playing
field with the force of rhinos and
hearthstone never eases back on the
atmosphere you get some idea of what
you're up against once hearthstone boots
you out of the short tutorial campaign
with the starter mage deck and into the
larger world to unlock the other classes
you have to fight the warriors that use
them whether they be AI or random
players unlocking all the classes
involves a zigzag of clicking on
different AI decks and testing the
waters until you find a deck you feel
comfortable with and then come the
pressures of deck building luckily
hearthstone makes this process
incredibly fun the game periodically
tosses new cards your way and in the
custom deck panel the suggest a card
feature helps make sure you have at
least a fighting chance against other
players you can fork out cash for
additional booster packs though you
probably won't feel the need to pay real
money in the early hours at higher
levels however good cards get so
numerous that hearthstone starts feeling
more like roulette than strategy
thankfully Blizzard provides an
alternative to any resulting frustration
that's the arena mode which requires
either cash or gold to play it's here
that hearthstone pushes your deck
building skills to their limits it
presents you with three random decks one
of which you need to whittle down to 30
cards to stay in the arena mode you have
to keep winning there's little doubt
that luck plays in
victory but achieving a victory delivers
the satisfaction that you won the match
on your own hearthstone is off to a good
start and its popularity will further
explode once it makes the leap to
tablets barring a failure of cataclysmic
proportions this is one open beta that
should serve as a model for all others
you